all right let's get into this week's
mailbag you can write in info
davidpakman.com um i i should say after
the deluge and some angry emails last
week the number of emails we get far
exceeds the five to ten that i can look
at
uh during the mailbag segment we get a
few hundred emails every day uh multiply
that by seven days a week you can
quickly see
why we can't get to all of them so info
davidpakman.com but emailing is no
guarantee that uh your email will make
it into the mailbag let's start with
today's first emails from chris chris
says hey david hope you're well
what if democrats or left-leaning people
started up a foe right-wing party in
order to steal votes from the
republicans it might be hard to pull off
the lie to make it seem authentic but
politics is a dirty game after all
if they could divert votes then mission
accomplished if they actually win then
mission accomplished just something i
was musing over for a bit of fun you
know i'm not totally sure that that's
legal there was this case actually i
think it involved i think it's still
going on it involves matt gates in
florida
about the idea of him being involved in
supporting like a
sort of diversion candidate uh and and
this is exactly the idea that chris is
pointing out i think that there's some
legal issue with it actually although i
don't remember exactly what it is
um i don't really have
a moral problem with it
um
in in a sort of traditional sense
but i question whether it would really
work and at the end of the day
obviously if it's against the law then
it shouldn't be done but even if it's
not i'm just not sure that a fake
right-wing party
would really work
other than maybe in
a few districts but i'd be willing to
think about the logistics a little more
and and maybe i'd have my mind changed
on that uh kevin wrote in
kevin says
this is a video clip that aired on cbs
morning news a month ago the story is
about the debate on requiring children
to wear masks in school or not
at 2 34 into the video a frustrated
parent says to the school board science
is not fact science is meant to be
challenged keep up the great work david
enjoy your youtube channel
here's this is this is actually a very
interesting topic
um increasingly you hear from people on
the right things like
science has been wrong
and you have to be allowed to challenge
science
both of those statements are true
but you've got to challenge science with
science and contrary to like this is
what makes science different than
religious beliefs
in most organized religion as well as in
cults
you're not rewarded for challenging the
orthodoxy and the teachings of the
pastor cult leader whatever
science on the other hand first of all
has a self-correcting mechanism where
hopefully we can duplicate results we do
more studies and there's also pretty big
financial and fame rewards if you were
able to disprove some major accepted
theory in science but you've got to do
it sorry as i hit my mic you've got to
do it with science and so simply coming
in and saying well i challenge the
science of vaccines with my opinion
that they do this or that they do that
or my pastor's feeling that they do this
and that it's absolutely true that
science is meant to be challenged the
scientific method includes such a
framework for those challenges but that
doesn't mean anyone's opinion is just as
valid of a challenge or alternative to
the accepted scientific view so often
with these people there's like this
kernel of truth
but it's completely misunderstood and
misapplied
more people continue to write in about
the trump flu pandemic thing uh 1917 flu
1918 flu as many of you know donald
trump started saying the 1917 flu even
though it's 1918 and he kept saying it
some people said oh no he's saying 17
because 17 is the 17th letter in the
alphabet i'm sorry q is the 17th letter
in the alphabet it's a signal to q anon
a t wrote in and has a different idea
and says sir
your
1918-1917 flu analysis being a product
of trump's narcissism got me laughing
that's my theory on why trump eats
well-done steaks with ketchup when asked
sir how would you like it cooked would
you like it rare medium well done
trump answered not understanding the
question of course i want it well done
like correctly done and that same
narcissism prevented him from sending
his dry steak back to partially remedy
his predicament he used ketchup because
it was there when asked why he declared
it's how he always eats his steak i wish
this were true but the simpler
explanation may be a burnt steak with
ketchup most resembles his favorite
hamburgers anyhow thanks for bringing
some sanity to the world appreciate what
you do yeah i think there's a lot to
that not that this is like the most
important issue
but i do think often with trump
it's like when he started saying plasma
instead of plasma and maybe someone went
to him and said it's plasma and he was
like no no no i say plasma maybe nobody
did
and he has no uh awareness that he may
be saying something wrong but i think
that the narcissism is a more likely
thing than it's a signal to queue he
called it the 1917 flu
maybe someone corrected him or he
certainly must have seen it on the news
but he decided now i i call it the 1917
flu i think that that's a very plausible
uh scenario
next email today is from chris
chris this is very interesting chris
says david
i live in texas
and identify as a republican but frankly
i'm embarrassed to be one at this point
in time
it seems a large number of republicans
currently in office don't live in
reality i believe as long as our
lawmakers have the us versus them
mindset
they will never come together for the
good of the people
it is time for the american people to
get off the couch and vote to remove
these stagnant lawmakers and replace
them with individuals who will put the
people first is it time to form a common
sense party i enjoy the show and
appreciate you shining a light on things
no matter what side of the fence they
are on listen i have no problem with
the idea the the idea of a common sense
party has been floated many times before
to some degree i think it's kind of what
andrew yang is trying to do with the
forward party andrew sent me his book
and we're trying to get him on the show
for an interview soon
but often what you end up with in these
situations is that there will be some
seemingly reasonable people from the
right like chris
who might be good faith participants in
such a common sense party
but very quickly you realize the vast
majority of those people
don't really have any common sense and
you can't really involve them
because their ideas are terrible
and they're not willing to have their
minds changed and so there's really no
practical way that you can include them
and that's what we often end up uh sort
of bumping up against for lack of a
better term and so i love the idea i
would love to be able to say hey you
know what if we keep the left
but then we include just like the same
right then on average we'll have a more
reasonable
there end up being we end up with very
few people like chris who we can
actually include and then then what you
end up risking is
it appeals to more democrats than
republicans and just hurts democrats and
leads to republicans being elected due
to being a spoiler and that's a disaster
that is not something i can
like in good faith really support if
it's going to even further sink the
country
into the bad so
send me your thoughts i mean is my is my
analysis too negative too pessimistic
let me know
elizabeth wrote in
about americans refusing the covet
vaccine
for
religious beliefs
elizabeth says david hopefully you can
clear this up for me
i recently saw on the news a woman who
was upset
because she was threatened to be removed
from the kidney transplant list because
she refused to get a covet vaccine
stating religious belief what religion
would prohibit vaccination
but allow an organ transplant i believe
this is just an avenue people are using
to stronghold their refusal to get the
covet vaccine can you shed light on this
love listening to your show thanks for
what you do yeah i don't have a specific
answer but it's a it's a good question
which is
the religions that tend to be just
skeptical of medical treatment like
christian science is one where i once
knew someone who
um worked with a christian scientist who
said listen if i were to like get hurt
or it was a kind of a more dangerous job
you can't just call an ambulance you've
got to call my pastor
the pastor needs to first pray for me
and authorize
what needs to happen including whether
the ambulance can take me or whatever i
ass i don't know but it would seem to me
if an organization like that
would have as much of a problem with
organ transplants as as much as the
vaccine or there would be some kind of
double standard
i don't actually know are there
religions where an organ transplant is
okay but vaccination really is not okay
i'm not aware of them my instinct is
that elizabeth is probably
on to something here
and that so-called religious objections
to vaccination um are often just ways to
try to stop conversation it's sort of
like you know the right likes to say
when the left doesn't like a
conversation they go that's racist and
everybody goes oh and gets scared and
backs away from the conversation
similarly
um
i think that
my religion says i can't get vaccinated
um could could be used similarly here's
another interesting vaccine question
this one's from michael michael says hey
david when i hear all these anti-vaxxed
people incorrectly scream about gene
therapy what michael's referring to is
some people say
the mrna vaccines aren't vaccines
they're gene therapies michael says when
i hear them scream about that i wonder
what's wrong with gene therapy i'm not
an expert on the subject but isn't gene
therapy how we would eventually cure
such diseases as cancer diabetes and
dementia to name a few i always thought
of gene therapy as the holy grail of
medicine relating to longevity just
wanted to share that thought yeah i mean
listen i'm not an expert on that so i
don't i shouldn't really comment
specifically but this
reminds me
of the entire the vaccine makes you
magnetic it magnetizes you do we know
for sure that being magnetized is bad
and what i mean by that is it's sort of
a joke but
have the anti-vaxxers who say the
vaccine magnetizes your arm or your
whole body have they said why it's bad
to be magnetized
understanding the problems with metal
implants and mris you know we could we
could imagine some some reasons but the
point is they don't really ever say that
they just say well it it's it's it's
this and therefore it's assumed to be
bad is it bad if the vaccine worked via
gene therapy
maybe that's okay as long as it protects
you from serious covet and death so very
very good point
um from mike there and then here's a
little bonus for you this one's from
youtube
this is just wild
someone wrote to me and they said
reread the fda website
idle approved for eau not eua eau or oh
the word for water in french
emergency use authorized requiring
madonna
jnj pfizer
you paid opposition remember it's the
anti-vaxxers getting paid not the people
reporting the science
but i did not know
that the fda was now by emergency use
requiring madonna songs be played i find
that extremely authoritarian if people
don't like madonna they shouldn't be
forced to listen to madonna i think that
that's absolutely absolutely horrible
obviously this is just riddled with
misspellings they met moderna by madonna
they meant eua rather than eau
boy
oh boy this is um
you know there there's
there's two views about something like
this one is these are obviously foreign
trolls because the english is such a
disaster
um
the other side of it is unfortunately
there are people who write adults who
write like this in the united states and
that is
a really really sad commentary
on the state of education in the united
states and i don't mean teachers are bad
but just the ability of your average
person i mean this is is this considered
partial illiteracy is this so bad that
we we actually this is a this is a sort
of
partial illiteracy if someone writes
like this i don't know
i don't know but it's certainly very
very scary
you can write to me info
davidpakman.com remember just writing to
me doesn't guarantee that your email
will be chosen but it is info
davidpakman.com you can also sign up for
the bonus show an extra show every day
at joinpackman.com
sign up today it's a beautiful thing